The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, so
every once in a while,
I stop and try to do a
little bit of reflection,
since we've--
have so many methods flying
through this semester
that I want to just--
once again, let's
say where we've been,
where we're going, what
we have, what we can do,
what we can't do, and why
we're going to do something
different today--
so just a little
reflection here.
We've been talking, obviously,
about optimal control.
There's two major approaches
to optimal control
that we've focused on--
well, three, I guess.
In some cases, we've done
analytical optimal control.
And I think, by now,
you appreciate that,
although it was often--
only works in special cases--
linear quadratic regulators
and things like that--
the lessons we
learned from that help
us design better algorithms.
And things like LQR can fit
right into more complicated
non-linear algorithms to
make them click, so I think,
absolutely, it's essential to
understand the things we can do
analytically in
optimal control--
even though they
crap out pretty early
in the scale of complexity
that we care about.
So mostly, that's good
for linear systems
and even restricted
there, linear systems
with quadratic costs
and things like that.
And then we talked about
major direction number
two was the dynamic programming
and value iteration approach.
And the big idea there right
was that, because we've
written our cost functions
over time to be additive,
the big idea really was
that we're going to learn--
we're going to figure out
the cost-to-go function--
the value function,
the value iteration--
and from there, we
can just extract that.
That captures all of
the long-term reasoning
we have to do about the system.
From that, we can extract the
optimal control decisions.
And it's actually
very efficient.
I hope, by now, you agree with
me that it's very efficient,
because if you think about it,
it's solving for an entire--
solving for the optimal policy
for every possible initial
condition in times that
are comparable to what
we're doing for single initial
conditions in the loop cases.
But it only works
in low dimensions,
and it has some
discretization issues.
And then the third
major approach--
I called it policy search.
And we focused mostly,
in the policy search,
on loop trajectory optimization.
But I tried to make
the point early--
and I'm going to make the point
again in a lecture or two--
that it's really not
restricted to thinking
about loop trajectories.
So when I first
said policy search,
I said we could be
looking for parameters
of a feedback controller of a--
the linear gain matrix
of a linear feedback.
We could do a lot of
things, but we quickly
started being specific
in our algorithms
in trying to optimize some loop
tape with direct colocation
with shooting.
But the ideas really are
more general than that,
and I'm going to-- we're
going to have a lecture soon
about how to do
these kind of things
with function approximation,
and do more general feedback
controllers.
These worked in higher
dimensional systems,
had local minima--
all the problems
you know by now.
OK, good-- so for
our model systems,
we got pretty far with that.
In the cases where
we knew the model,
we assumed that the
model was deterministic
and sensing was clean--
everything like that.
We could make our simulations
do pretty much what we wanted
with those bag of tricks.
Then I threw in the stochastic
optimal control case.
We said, what happens if the
models aren't deterministic?
Analytical optimal control--
I didn't really talk about
it, but there are still
some cases where you can do
analytical optimal control.
The linear quadratic
Gaussian systems
are the clear example of that.
We said that value
iteration for this--
although I was quickly
challenged on it,
I said, basically,
it was no harder
to do value iteration
stochastic optimization, where
now our goal is to minimize
some expected value
of a long-term cost.
Value iteration we
basically said and almost
no harder to do the case with
transition probabilities flying
around.
And in fact, the
barycentric grids
that we used in the value
duration way back there
I told you actually has a
more clean interpretation
as taking a continuous--
you can think of it as being
a continuous
deterministic system,
and converting it
into a discrete state
stochastic system.
Remember, the interpolation
that you do in the barycentric
actually takes
exactly the same form
as some transition probabilities
when you're going from--
you've got some
grid, and you want
to know where you're going
to go from simulating forward
from this with some
action for some dt,
you can approximate that
as being some fraction
here, some fraction
here, some fraction here.
And it turns out to be
exactly equivalent to saying
that there's some
probability I get here,
some probability I get here,
and the like.
So value iteration
really, in that sense,
can solve stochastic
problems nicely.
The other major approach,
the policy search,
can still work for
stochastic problems.
In some cases, you can
compute the gradient
of the expected
value with respect
to your parameters analytically,
with a [INAUDIBLE] update.
In other cases, you
can do sampling based,
Monte Carlo based
estimates, and I'm
going to get more into that.
We're going to talk
more about that,
but the takeaway messages,
when things get stochastic,
both of these
methods still work.
And they work in
slightly different ways,
but you can make
both of those work
And then, last week, John threw
a major wrench into things.
Sorry.
That wasn't supposed to
be a statement about John.
John made your life
better by telling you
that some of these statements--
some of these algorithms
work even if you
don't know the model.
And he talked about doing
policy search without a model.
And the big idea there was that
actually fairly simple looking
algorithms, which just perturb
the-- which try different
parameters--
run a trial, try
different parameters--
simple sampling algorithms
can estimate the same thing
we would do with our policy
gradient, the gradient
of the expected reward with
respect to the parameters.
Even the simplest
thing is let's change
my parameters a little
bit, see what happened.
That gives me a sample
from this gradient.
And if I do it enough times,
I pull enough samples,
and I can--
I get a sample of
the expected returns.
If you think back,
that's why we try
to stick in stochastic
optimal control
before we got to that,
because John also
told you the nice interpretation
of these algorithms
in the stochastic--
that, even if the plant
that you're measuring from
is stochastic or if the
sensors are-- there's noise,
then actually, still, these
same sampling algorithms
can estimate these
gradients for you nicely.
I think John also
made the point--
and I want to make it again--
you would never use these
algorithms if you had a model.
They're beautiful, but
probably, if you have a model--
maybe, if you have
a model and you're
a very patient
person, but very lazy,
then you might try to use
this, because you can type it
in in a few minutes,
but it's going
to take a lot longer to run.
And the reason for
that is it's going
to require many [INAUDIBLE]
requires many more simulations.
In fact, it just
requires many simulations
to estimate a single gradient--
policy gradient.
Now, the next thing I'm
going to say is a little more
controversial, but most people
would say that the limiting
case, the best you could
possibly do with these
reinforce type algorithms-- are
you raising your hand or just--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: No-- sorry.
The best thing you can do with
these reinforced algorithms,
if you really--
the best performance you could
expect is a shooting algorithm.
And it's really, I should say,
a first-order shooting method.
It's really just doing gradient
descent by doing trials.
And when we talked
about shooting methods,
I actually said never do
first-order shooting methods.
I made a big point.
I said never do
this, never do this--
because if you go to the
second-order methods,
things converge faster.
You don't have to
pick learning rates.
You can handle constraints.
So there are people that do a
bit of more second-order policy
gradient algorithms, but
that's not the standard yet.
So you should really think of
those as cool systems that,
if you--
cool algorithms that, if
you don't have a model,
you can almost do
a shooting method.
Why do I say that's a
controversial statement?
Could you imagine somebody
standing up and saying,
this is actually better
than doing gradient descent?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
So the one advantage is that
it's doing stochastic gradient
descent.
And there are people
out there that
really believe stochastic
gradient descent can outperform
even higher order
methods in certain cases,
just because of their ability
to, by virtue of being random--
this is not some magical
property we've endowed.
This is [? Because ?] the
algorithm is a little crazy.
It bounces out of local minima.
So for that reason, it does
have all the strong optimization
claims that a stochastic
gradient descent algorithm has.
There's another point
to make, though,
and I think John made this too.
The performance of this--
and John's done nice--
written nice paper on this--
the performance
you'd expect, meaning
the number of trials it would
take to learn to optimize
your cost function--
the performance of these
reinforced type algorithms--
it degrades with a
number of parameters
you're trying to tune.
So remember, the
fundamental idea was--
and the way I like
to think of it
is, imagine you're at a mixer
station in a sound recording
studio, and you're
looking through the glass,
and you've got a
robot over there.
You've got all your
knobs set in some place,
and your robot
does its behavior,
and then you give it a score.
You turn your
knobs a little bit,
you see how the robot acts.
You turn it off a
little bit more.
And your job is to just twist
these knobs in a way that
finds the way down the gradient,
and gets your robot doing
what you want to do.
That maybe is a
demystifying way to think
about this everything, which
is mathematically beautiful,
but really, it's
just turning knobs.
If you have a model and you
can compute the gradient,
then you don't have to guess
the way you turn knobs.
You should always use that
model to turn the knobs
in the right direction.
And also, if you think about
that analogy, the number of--
the length of time it's
going to take you to optimize
your function is
going to depend on how
many knobs you have to turn.
If I have 100 knobs
in front of me
and I change them
all a little bit--
I see how my robot
acted-- then it's
going to be hard for me
to figure out exactly
which knob to assign credit to.
The fewer knobs
I have to change,
the faster I can estimate
which knobs were important,
and climb down a gradient.
I still say, when
you have a model,
you should always
use it, because you
can estimate the gradients.
You can turn the knobs
in the right way.
But in the case where you don't
have a model, it's actually--
they're very nice
classes of algorithms.
This knob tuning thing
sounds ridiculous.
Maybe, if I have
even an [INAUDIBLE],,
if you have a good model
of the [INAUDIBLE],,
then maybe you shouldn't-- you
should definitely be using it.
But if you have a very
complicated system,
and the performance only depends
on the number of parameters,
then it--
I just want to make
the point that it's--
they're actually pretty powerful
for some control problems.
And the ones that we're
working on in my group
are fluid dynamics
control problems,
but specifically if you have
problems where you can get away
with the small
number of parameters,
but you have a very
complicated unknown dynamics.
And actually, those
algorithms are really--
make a lot of sense to me.
So the performance of these
randomized policy search
algorithms-- it goes with
the number of parameters
you're trying to tune.
I could be sitting in
this mixing station,
and I could be twittering
four parameters
and having a simple
pendulum do its thing,
or I could be sitting in
there turning these four knobs
and having a
Navier-Stokes simulation,
with some very complicated
fluid doing something,
and the amount of time it takes
me to twiddle those parameters
is the same.
One of the strongest
properties of these algorithms
is that, by virtue of
ignoring the model,
they're actually insensitive
to the model complexity.
So in my group, we're
really trying to push--
in some problems where the
dynamics are unknown and very
complicated and a
lot of the community
is trying to build
better models of this,
we're trying to say, well, maybe
before you have perfect models,
we can do some of these
model-free search algorithms
to build good controllers
without perfect models.
Are people OK with that
array of techniques?
Yeah?
You have a good
arsenal of tools?
Can you see the
obvious place where
I'm trying to go next, now
that I've set it up like this?
We did value methods and
policy search methods
for the simple case, then we did
value methods and policy search
methods for the
stochastic case, then
we did policy methods
for the model-free case.
So how about we do model-free
value methods today?
But I know it's a complicated
web of algorithms,
so I want to make sure that I
stop and say that kind of stuff
every once in a while.
So what's the difference between
a policy method and a value
method?
So value duration-- like I
said, it's very, very efficient.
The way we represented
value iteration with a grid,
and having to solve
every possible state
at every possible time, is
the extreme form of value--
of the value methods.
In general, we can try to build
approximate value methods--
estimates of our value
function that don't
require the big discretization.
So actually, last
week, at the meeting--
one of the meetings I was
at, I met Gerry Tesauro.
And Gerry Tesauro is the
guy who did TD-Gammon.
Anybody heard of TD-Gammon?
Yeah?
[INAUDIBLE] knows TD-Gammon.
I don't know what year it was.
It was 20 years ago now.
One of the big success stories
for reinforcement learning
was that they
built a game player
based on reinforcement
learning that
could play backgammon
with the experts
and beat the experts
at backgammon.
Now, backgammon's actually
not a trivial game.
It's got a huge state space--
huge state space.
I don't play
backgammon, but I know
there's a lot of bits
going around there.
It's stochastic, because
you roll a die every once
in a while.
So it's actually not
some complicated--
not some simple game.
In some ways, it's
surprising that it
was solved before
checkers and these others.
Maybe it's just because not
enough people play backgammon,
so you can beat
the experts easier.
I don't know.
But we were playing
competition style--
beat the best humans
at backgammon--
well before checkers and chess,
because of a value-based--
model-free, value-based
method for backgammon.
So Gerry Tesauro actually
use neural networks,
and he learned, from
watching the game,
a value function for the game.
What does that mean?
So what do you do when
you play backgammon--
or whatever game you play?
I'm not trying to
dump on that game.
I just haven't played it myself.
So if you look at a go
board or a chess board,
you don't think about every
single state that's possibly
in there, but you're able
to quickly look at the board
and get a sense of if
you're winning or losing.
If you were to make this move,
my life should get better.
And there are
serious people that
think that the natural
representation for very
complicated physical
control processes
or very complicated
game playing scenarios
is to not learn actually
the policy directly,
but to just learn a
sense of what's good
and what's bad directly, learn
a value function directly.
And then we [INAUDIBLE]
from value iteration.
That captures all
that's hard about--
that captures the
entire long-term look
ahead in the optimal
control problem.
Once I have a value
function, if I
have a value function I believe,
if I want to make an action,
all I have to do is think about,
well, if I made this action,
my value would get
better by this much.
If I made this action, my value
would get better by this much.
And I just pick the action that
maximizes my expected value.
Now, the good thing
about value-based methods
is that they tend to
be very efficient.
You can simultaneously think
about lots of different states
at a time.
Just like value duration,
it's very efficient
to learn value methods.
And historically, in the
reinforcement learning world,
nobody ever really did
policy search methods
until the early '90s.
There was at least
15 years where
people were doing cool things
with robots, and game playing,
and things like that, where
almost everybody, every paper
was talking about, how do
you learn a value function?
How do you learn
a value function
if you have to put in a
function approximator?
Or how do you do a value
function if this, if this?
So really, even though
I did it second,
this was actually the
core of reinforcement
learning for a long time.
How do you learn
a value function?
How do you estimate
the cost-to-go--
ideally, the
optimal cost-to-go--
given trial and error
experience with the robot?
So that's today's problem.
Good-- so we can make
it easier by thinking
about a sub-problem first.
And that's really
policy evaluation,
which is the problem
of, given I have--
I have my dynamics, of
course, and some policy pi,
I want to estimate
or compute J of pi,
the long-term potentially
expected reward
of executing that
feedback policy
on that robot, potentially
from all states at all times.
So this is maybe equivalent to
what I just said about chess.
So my value function for
chess might look different
than somebody who knows
how to play chess.
I look at the board, and
most of the time, I'm losing,
and my actions are going
to be chosen differently,
because I wouldn't even know
what to do if my rook ended up
over there.
And the optimal value function,
given I was acting optimally,
might look very different.
But for me, the first problem is
just estimate what's my cost--
the cost of executing
my current game playing
strategy, my current
control-- feedback controller
on this robot, or this game?
Now, there is
something culturally
different from the
reinforcement learning
value-based communities,
and I'm going
to go ahead and make
that switch now.
Most of the time, these
things are infinite horizon
discounted problems.
I'll say it's discrete
time just to keep it clean,
because then it's easy to
write [INAUDIBLE] equals t
to infinity here, gamma to the--
let me just do it like this.
Let's assume that it's
completely feedback.
That'll just keep me
writing less symbols
for the rest of
the lecture here.
0 to infinity, gamma to the
n, xn, and then pi of xn,
where my action is always
pulled directly from pi--
I mentioned it once
before, but why
do people do discounted things?
Lots of reasons why people
do discounted things-- first
of all, if you have
infinite horizon rewards,
there's just a practical issue.
If you're not careful,
infinite horizon rewards
will blow up on you.
So if you put some sort
of decaying factor gammas,
typically, it's constrained
to be less than 1
just so you don't have to
worry about things blowing up
in the long term.
But you can make it
1, and then you just
have to be more careful that
you get to a fixed point
[INAUDIBLE] cost,
or whatever it is.
Let's just put some decaying
cost on future experiences.
Philosophically, some
people really like this.
So a lot of the problems
we've talked about
are very episodic in nature.
We talked about designing
trajectories from time 0
to time final.
What's the optimal thing?
If you just want
to live your life--
presumably, you don't
know exactly when
you're going to die.
You're going to maximize
some long-term reward.
You'd like it to be infinite,
but realistically, the things
that are going to
happen to me tomorrow
are more important to
me that the things that
are happening in the
very far, distant future.
So some people, philosophically,
just like having this
as a cost function
for a robot that's
alive executing
an online policy,
worrying about short-term
things a little bit more,
but thinking about
into the future.
And that knob is
controlled by gamma.
Almost all of the
RL tools can be
made compatible with the
episodic non-discounted cases,
but culturally, like I said,
they're almost always written
in this form, so I
thought it'd makes sense
to switch to that
form for a little bit.
So how do we estimate J pi of
x, given that kind of a setup?
Let's do the model-based
case, just as a first case.
Let's say I have a good model.
I made it look
deterministic here,
but we can, in general, do
this for stochastic things.
Let me do the model-based
Markov chain version first.
So you remember, in general, we
said that the optimal control
problem for discrete
states, discrete actions,
stochastic transitions looked
like a Markov decision process,
where we have some
discrete state space,
we have a probability
transition matrix,
where T-I-J is probability
of transitioning from I to J.
And we have some cost.
And in the graph sense,
I tend to write--
we tend to write the cost as--
instead of being
[INAUDIBLE] action,
we can just write it
as the probability of--
the cost of transitioning from
state I to state J. Good--
now, in the Markov
decision processes
that we talked about before,
the transition matrix
was a function of
the action you chose.
Your goal was to choose
the action, which
made your transition
matrices have the optimal--
choose the best transition
matrices for your problem.
In policy evaluation,
where we're saying,
we're trying to figure out the
probability of the cost-to-go
of running this policy,
then the actions are--
the parameterization by
action disappears again.
It's not a Markov
decision process.
It falls back right into
being a Markov chain.
So it's a simple picture now.
We have a graph there's some
probabilities of transitioning
from each state to each
action, from each state,
because my actions
are predetermined.
If I'm in some state, I'm
going to take this action
based on pi.
And each transition
incurs some cost,
and my goal is to
move around the graph
in a way that incurs minimal
long-term cost and expected
value.
So that's a good way
to start figuring out
how to do policy evaluation.
So now, in this discrete state
transition matrix [INAUDIBLE]
this form, I'm going to rewrite
J pi as being a function of i,
where i is from--
i is drawn from S, some--
it's one discrete state.
And it's the expected value of
G-I-N to I [INAUDIBLE] plus 1.
I should say another funny
example I just remembered.
So I gave an analogy
of playing a game.
You might look at the
board and figure out
what's the value of
being in certain states.
People think it's relevant
in your brains too.
So there's actually a lot of
work in neuroscience these days
which probes activity of
certain neurons in your brain,
and finds neurons that basically
respond with the expected value
of your cost-to-go function.
They have monkeys
doing these tasks,
where they pull levers or
blink at the right time,
and get certain rewards.
And there's neurons
that fire correlated
with their expected
reward in ways that are--
they design an experiment so
it doesn't look like something
that's correlated with the
action they're going to choose,
but it does look
like it's correlated
with expected reward.
And interestingly,
when they learn--
as the monkeys learn
during the task,
you can actually
see that they start
making predictions
accurately when
they're close to the reward.
They're about to get juice, and
then, a few minutes later, they
can predict when they're a
minute away from getting juice.
And then, if you look at
it a couple of days in,
they're able to
predict when they're
a half hour from getting
juice or something like this.
I think the structure of trying
to learn the value function
is very real, especially if
you're a juice-deprived monkey.
So let's continue on here.
How do you compute J
pi, given this equation?
J is a vector now.
Well, first of all the dynamic
programming recursion let's
us write it like this.
J of ik is the expected
value of taking one step--
the one step cost plus
the discount factor
times the future.
The reason people choose this
form for the discount factor
is that the Bellman recursion
just looks like that.
You just put a gamma
in front of everything.
We can take the expected value
of this with our Markov chain
notation and say
it's the sum over i k
plus 1's of Tik ik plus
1 times g ik, ik plus 1.
Keep putting pi everywhere
so we remember that.
Pi k plus 1.
The expected value just is a sum
over probabilities of getting
each of the outcomes.
So you can use that
transition matrix.
And in vector form, since
I have a finite number
of discrete states,
I can just write
that as J is g plus gamma TJ,
where the i-th element of g
is Keep my pi's everywhere.
Everybody agree
with those steps?
OK.
So what's J-- J pi?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Mm-hmm.
RUSS TEDRAKE: I have to
go to a vector form for J,
so I just put it over here.
I'm saying that the i-th
element of the vector g--
this is my vector g now--
and the i-th element of my
vector g has that T in there--
absolutely.
Yep.
So it's the expected
value of g there.
OK, so what's J pi?
So lo and behold,
policy evaluation
on a Markov chain with known
probabilities is trivial.
It's this.
It's almost free to compute.
I could tell you exactly
what my long-term cost
is going to be just by
knowing my transition matrix.
That's something I think
we forget, because we're
going to get into
models that look more
complicated than
that, but remember,
if the transition matrix,
it's trivial to compute
the long-term cost
for a Markov chain.
So let me just show you why
that's relevant, for instance.
All right, so I told you about
this the day the clock stopped.
I kept telling you about it
[INAUDIBLE] And for the record,
do you know what
happened that day?
The clock physically stopped.
Michael debugged it.
There was a little
piece of paint
that blocked it at
exactly 3:05 the day
I was giving that lecture.
That was a hard one
to catch, to be fair.
So one of my favorite models
of stochastic processes
in discrete time,
for instance, is
taking our rimless wheels,
our passive walking models,
and putting them
on rough terrain.
So this is the rimless wheel,
where now, every time it
takes a step, the ramp angle is
drawn from some distribution.
Now, in real life, maybe you
don't roll rimless wheels
on that kind of slope, but
the contention in that paper
was that actually, every
floor is rough terrain,
and you actually have to worry
about the stochastic dynamics
all the time.
And if you want to take--
you can take your
compass-gait model
and put it on rough
terrain, and you
could take the [? kneed ?] model
and put it on rough terrain.
These are the passive
things, so they
can't walk on very much rough
terrain before they fall down.
But they can.
They can walk on rough terrain.
And then you want to ask
complicated questions
about this, maybe.
You want to say,
given my terrain
was drawn from
some distribution,
how far should I expect my robot
to walk before it falls down?
That sounds like a hard
question to answer.
It's trivial to
answer, actually.
So this equation is exactly
what drove that work.
We built the transition matrix
on the [INAUDIBLE] map, saying,
given it's passive--
there's no actions
to choose from--
given it's passive, what's
the probability of being
in this new state,
given the terrain's
drawn from some distribution
given it's at a current state.
The cost function was
1 if it keeps taking
a step, 0 if it fell over.
And you compute this, and it--
what does it tells you?
It tells you the expected number
of steps until you fall down--
period.
On shot.
Simple calculation.
It's so simple.
The bad part is you have
to discretize your state
space to do it.
But if you're willing to
discretize your state space,
then you can make very long-term
predictions about your model
with--
just like that,
to the point where
we are trying to say that people
who talk about stability--
people are coming up with
metrics for stability
and walking systems.
They say, why not just do this?
Why not actually
compute, given some model
of the terrain, how
many steps you'd expect
to take until it falls down?
That's what you'd
like to compute,
and it's not hard to compute,
so you should do that.
So that's a clear place where
policy evaluation by itself--
there's lots of cases where
you have a robot that's
doing something, it's
got a control system,
and you just want to
verify how well it works.
If you're trying to verify it
an expected value, it's easy.
Just do the Monte Carlo-- or
sorry-- the Markov chain thing.
But what happens if
I don't have a model?
That's what we're supposed
to be talking about today.
Can we do the same thing
if we don't have a model?
I had to know T. I had to
know the-- all the transition
probabilities in order
to make that calculation.
What happens if we don't have a
model-- we just have a robot we
can run a bunch of times?
How do you do it?
What would you do,
if I asked you--
I say, I like your robot.
I want to know how long it
tends to run before it fails.
How would you do it?
There's an easy answer.
You could run it a bunch of
times and take an average.
We know that these value
functions are state-dependent,
so it's a little more
painful than that.
Technically, you're
going to have
to run it a bunch of times from
every single initial condition,
but you could do that.
And actually, that's
not totally crazy.
So I want to know
how much cost I'm
going to incur-- in the case
of the walking robot, how
many steps it's going to take
on average before it falls down.
First thing to try--
don't have to know the
transition matrices-- just
run it a bunch of times.
So if I say Jn i, the n-th
time I run my robot, I incur--
I just keep track of the cost.
I keep track of how
many steps it took.
much gold it found--
whatever your cost function is.
The thing I'm trying to
estimate is the expected value
of that long-term cost.
But any one trial--
I get this thing out
as a random variable.
I could take the expected
value of the random variable.
I can make a nice
estimate of J pi i
by just running it a bunch
of times and taking--
doesn't sound very
elegant, but it works.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: What?
Sum over k.
Good.
Thank you, thank you.
Sum over k.
[INAUDIBLE] you've corrected
both simultaneously.
OK, so a couple
of nuances here--
so first of all, I have an
infinite horizon cost function.
So this is only going
to be an approximation,
because I'm not going to
run this forever 10 times.
I'm going to run it for some
finite duration 10 times.
So in practice,
I'm actually going
to run something
that's big number.
But that's OK because
this discount factor
means that a finite trial
approximation should
be a pretty good estimate
of the long-term.
And if I run it from initial
condition i long enough,
then I should be able
to take an average
and get the expected
[INAUDIBLE]..
There's lots of ways you
can do that kind of thing
if you don't want to do all
the bookkeeping of remembering
where you've been.
You don't have to remember
all of these things.
You can do an online
version, incremental.
You can say that
my J hat is just--
my J hat pi is just J hat pi--
I can guess an initial
J hat, and then,
every time I get
a new trial, I'll
just move my estimate
towards that trial.
And this is actually
an online version that
approximates that in batch.
This is just a
standard [INAUDIBLE]
that you can do
it more carefully.
I could choose these to
be a perfect weighting
but in general, this is actually
a pretty good approximation,
as the number of trials goes
up, to this sum without keeping
track of every J.
Every time, I'm just
going to do moving average
towards the new point, and
by changing a small amount,
it will converge.
This is a low-pass filter.
That's another way to say it.
It's a low-pass filter
that tries to get me to--
the mean of the J
samples I'm getting in.
So that gets rid of a
little bit of bookkeeping.
There's other things you can do.
Now, here's a really cool one.
Think about this, and tell me
if you think it's possible.
I'm going to tell you
in a minute how that--
if I have two policies, I can--
say, pi 1 and pi 2--
Do you believe that?
It's going to take a
little bit more machinery,
but just to see where we go.
Say I have two control systems.
I have the one that is
risky, and I ran it once,
and the thing fell down.
So I don't actually want
to run that 100 times.
I might break my robot.
Let's say I've got
a different policy
that I like a little better.
It's a little safer
to do evaluations on.
Can you imagine running
the safe policy, let's say,
to learn about the risky policy?
That's pretty cool idea, right?
What is wrong with this?
Typically done
with a q function.
I'll show you how to
say that in a second.
So there's lots of
ways you can do that.
You can run trials,
you can keep averages,
you can try to learn about one
trial by learning the other.
What the fundamental
idea here is
is that it requires
stochasticity.
You need that, in
policy, pi 1 and pi 2
have to change--
take the same actions
with some non-zero probability.
Pi 2 might be my risky policy,
and every once in a while,
with some small probability, it
takes a safe action, let's say.
And pi 1 is my safe policy,
but every once in a while, it
takes a risky action.
As long as these things
have some non-zero overlap
in probability space,
then I can actually
learn about what
it would have been
to do the more risky
thing by taking
the more conservative thing.
So policy evaluation's
a really nice tool.
But this feels slow.
The Monte Carlo
thing feels slow--
feels like I got to
run a lot of trials
from a lot of different
initial conditions.
And now you tell me
what the cost-to-go
is from this initial
condition, and let's say
I try this initial condition.
What do I do?
Do I just have to start over
and run trials from the get-go
again?
Well, that doesn't
seem very satisfying.
Approach number two
is bootstrapping.
I call it bootstrapping.
If I learned about the cost
of being in this state,
and I spent a long time learning
about the cost-to-go of being
in this state, and then
I go back and ask what's
the cost of being in
this state, if this one
transitions into
this one, then I
should be able to reuse what
I learned about the state
to make it faster to
learn about that state.
I didn't really plan to do it
with the steps on the floor,
but I hope that makes sense.
Maybe I could do it on a graph.
That's better, yeah?
Let's say I figured out
what J pi of this state is--
because I went from
here, and I went around,
and I did my stuff,
and I learned
pretty much what there is to
learn about here [INAUDIBLE]
policy.
And now I want to
know about this state.
Well, I should be
able to reuse the fact
that I've learned about
that to help me learn this
more quickly--
reasonable idea.
Using your estimate to inform
your future estimates is
an idea about
bootstrapping, reusing--
building on your current guess
to build a better future guess.
And here's how it could look
in the optimal control policy
evaluation sense.
What if I said my
online rule used
to be this, where I've got
some estimate J pi hat?
I'm going to run from 0
to some very large number
to estimate this, and
then make the update.
What if, instead, I
just took a single step
and I did this update?
Does that make sense to you?
Let's say I ask you to guess
the long-term cost here.
Instead of running all the
way to the end, what if I just
run a single step and
then use as my cost
my estimate for this,
the cost of going here
plus the gamma times the
cost of doing all that?
It's just using this one-step
cost as an estimate for when I
was going J-N of ik plus 1--
or sorry, J-N of ik.
Does that makes sense?
If I find myself in a lot of
different initial conditions,
I could take one step
and then use my guess
for the cost-to-go from that
step to the rest of the time.
Now, this starts feeling
a lot more appealing,
actually, because now
I don't have to think--
this actually got rid of
that whole episodic problem.
I don't have to go in
and run some fixed length
trial to approximate
the long-term thing.
I just take a single step,
use this as my estimate,
and I can just keep moving
through my Markov chain.
I don't have to ever reset.
And potentially, if I
visit states often enough--
I won't get into all
the details-- roughly,
it involves that
Markov chain being--
having ergodicity.
you have to be able to
visit all the states
with some non-zero
probability as you go along.
But if you visit the states--
each state infinitely often
is roughly the thing--
then this actually
will converge to J pi of ik.
So the ergodicity is actually
bad news for my walking robot,
because if my walking
robot falls down,
I'm going have to
pick it back up if I
want to get ergodicity back.
There are robots that
don't visit every state
every arbitrarily often.
But in the Markov
chain sense, that
doesn't seem like
such a bad assumption.
And if I'm willing to take
my robot when it falls down
and pick it back up--
which, by the way,
is about how I
spent the last year of my PhD--
then actually, I can
get ergodicity back.
OK, cool-- so that
makes sense, right?
I'm going to use my existing
estimate of the cost-to-go
to bootstrap my algorithm for
estimating the cost-to-go.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does the
transition [INAUDIBLE]
come into play at all?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It
does, because I'm
getting this from sampled data.
So this is actually drawn.
The expected value of this
update does the right thing.
So this update doesn't
have it, because this
is from a real trials.
But you should think
about this as a sample
from the real distribution.
Now, that's actually a
really good way for me
to lead into the next step.
These algorithms tend to be
a lot faster in practice than
those algorithms-- not only are
they a little bit more elegant,
because you don't have to reset
and run finite-length trials--
they tend to be a lot faster.
And the reason for that is
this here is really the--
it has the expected value of
future costs built into it.
Let me say that in the pictures.
There's two ways, I
could estimate this.
I could get here and then
I could take a single path.
Well, this one is not
rich enough for me
to make my point
here, but OK-- so I
could take a single
path through here
and get a single sample
estimating the long-term cost.
But if I instead use J pi,
J pi is the expected value
of going around
and living in this.
So by using this
update to bootstrap,
or if I just take
one step from here,
I get for free the expected
value of living over here
for a long time.
Does that make sense?
So J is building up a map
of the expected value,
because it's visiting things
often and it's-- drew this
online algorithm with
this low-pass filter.
He's basically doing an
expected value calculation.
By using my low-pass
filtered [INAUDIBLE] in here,
it's also--
it's getting the reward of--
maybe you could just say
it's filtering faster.
That's actually not a bad
way to think about it.
I've already got
this thing filtered,
so this one filters faster.
That's a pretty reasonable way
to think about it, actually.
OK.
So this quantity
here in the brackets,
this whole guy right here,
it's a very important quantity,
it comes up a lot.
It's called the temporal
difference error.
It's the difference that
I get from executing
my policy for one step and then
using the long-term estimate
compared to what I have
is my long-term estimate,
temporal difference error.
Now, if the system
was deterministic
and I had already converged,
then that temporal difference
there should be 0, because
this thing should be exactly--
predict the long-term thing.
If the system's stochastic, then
this temporal difference error
should be 0, on average.
It's comparing my
cost-to-go from ik,
given my 1 step plus the
cost-to-go from ik plus 1.
So those things-- you want
those to match, right?
You want that my 1 step
plus long-term prediction
should match my
long-term prediction,
if things are right.
They should match
an expected value.
So that thing's called the
temporal difference error,
and it's an important quantity
in reinforcement learning.
It makes sense to
write that down.
That's a reasonable
estimate for J.
n would be to take one step
and then do the other one,
but there's--
that seems a little
bit arbitrary.
Why don't I just do one
step and then use my lookup?
Thi sis the way Rich says it.
Why not do two steps and
then use my value function
to look up?
Or three steps-- why not
take, similarly, three steps,
and then use that
to look it up--
or 14 steps or
something like that.
Why should I arbitrarily
pick this one real data
and then look ahead, instead
of two real pieces of data
and my look ahead?
Well, there's no reason
that you actually
have to pick like that.
Can I just write the
inside part here?
I could have estimated
Jn ik as gik ik
plus 1 plus gamma gik plus 1
ik plus 2 plus gamma squared
J pi at ik plus 2.
That's a perfectly
good approximation too.
I could have done three-step.
I could have done four-step.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Say it again.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah I. I
haven't been writing it
that way because--
yeah.
I would have been fine
writing it that way.
At some point, I decided
to not write pi there,
and I'll just stay consistent
by not writing that.
OK, so Rich [INAUDIBLE] came
up with a clever algorithm
that's-- basically allows you to
seamlessly pick between the one
step, two step, three step,
n-step look ahead with a single
knob.
And it works.
It's called the TD
lambda algorithm.
And the basic idea
is that you want
to combine a lot of
these different updates
into a single update.
It sounds really
bizarre [INAUDIBLE]
so let me just say it.
Let's say I call my
estimate J of Jn,
with M step look ahead of ik.
M equals 0 to M gamma of M
gik plus M ik plus M plus 1.
Big M.
This is a big M. Big M.
Everything else is little m's.
That was the one step.
This is the two step.
In general, this is
the M step look ahead.
So it turns out there's
actually an efficient way
to compute this.
Let's call it something else--
p, p, p.
This one takes a
little time to digest.
But it turns out it's pretty
efficient to calculate
a weighted sum of the one
step, two step, three step--
onto forever--
sum of look-aheads
parameterized by another
parameter, lambda.
So when lambda's 1,
this thing turns out
to be basically
doing Monte Carlo.
And when lambda's 0,
this thing basically
is doing just the
one-step look ahead.
And when lambda is
somewhere in between,
it's doing some look
ahead using a few steps.
Does that makes sense at all?
It's a lot of terms
flying around here.
Even if you don't
completely love that,
just think of my estimate,
J of lambda being awaited,
basically something that,
where if lambda is 1,
it's going to be the very
long-term look ahead.
If lambda is 0, it's going to be
the very short-term look ahead.
And there's a
continuum in between,
a continuous knob I can
turn to say how far I'm
going to look ahead into
the future as my estimate
that I'm going to
use in that TD error.
And there's a whole
gamut in between.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Can
I say it again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Or can I read it?
1 minus lambda i just a
the normalization factor.
p equals 1 to infinity.
Lambda the p minus 1 J p--
where this is the
p step look ahead.
So this is a very
famous algorithm--
the TD lambda algorithm--
which allows you to
do policy evaluation
without knowing the
transition matrix,
doing bootstrapping
or Monte Carlo
in a simple single framework
with just a parameter lambda
to evaluate.
So it's a tweak.
And it turns out it uses
an eligibility trace,
just like in reinforce.
Did you get the
eligibility traces, John?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
Well, that's fine.
So it turns out to have
a really simple form.
I'll write it, because
it's so simple,
but it'll also be
in the notes, if you
want to spend more
time with it here.
OK, two observations--
first of all, this
looks no harder [INAUDIBLE]
than the original version I had,
pretty much.
It just requires one
extra variable, which
is this eligibility trace.
What does the eligibility
trace look like?
OK.
It starts off at 0.
There's an element for
every note in the graph.
Every time I visit the graph--
that node in the graph, I--
it goes up by 1,
and then it starts
forgetting based on
gamma and lambda,
as this discount factor.
And then, the next time I
visit it, it goes up by 1.
If I visit it a lot, it
can build up like this.
It's just a trace of memory
of when I visited this cell.
Does that makes sense,
this dynamics here?
Every time I visit the
cell, it goes up by 1,
and always, it's going
down exponentially.
It turns out, if you
just remember that,
the way that you've
visited cells in the past,
decade by this lambda-- as well
as gamma-- but this lambda--
which is the new term--
then it's enough to [INAUDIBLE]
this trivial update here,
scaled by the--
how often I visited
that cell recently.
Is it enough to accomplish this
seemingly bizarre combination
of short and
long-term look-aheads.
So it's a really simple,
really beautiful algorithm.
Just remember how-- when
I visited these cells,
and then make this TD error
update scaled by that,
and I've got the TD
lambda algorithm.
And what people can do is they--
people can prove that TD lambda
converges to the TD lambda
update that J hat will go to J
pi from any initial conditions.
So you can just guess J
randomly to begin with.
And if I run it, as I visit all
these states arbitrarily often,
it still makes that
ergodicity assumption.
Then I'll get my
policy evaluation out.
That's really cool--
simple algorithm.
Now, what people also realize
is that, when you start out,
and J is randomly initialized,
then it makes a lot of sense
to set lambda close to 1,
because bootstrapping has less
value when I just start out.
My estimate is
bad everywhere, so
why should I use my bad
estimate as my predictor?
So you start off-- you
keep lambda close to 1.
It does very long-term.
It does more Monte
Carlo style updates.
And as this estimate
starts converging
to the good estimate, you
start turning lambda down.
And with a cleverly
tuned timing of lambda,
you can get very fast
convergence compared
to the Monte Carlo algorithms.
You more and more bootstrap.
Excellent.
Well, time's up.
The clock is still moving
today, so I have to stop.
So the really cool thing--
we only talked about
policy evaluation today.
The next step is, how
do you do these value
methods to improve your policy?
And it turns, out in many cases,
if you make a current estimate
of your value function
and then, on every step,
you try to do the greedy
policy, epsilon greedy policy,
you basically-- you mostly
exploit your current estimate
of the value function, then
you can still prove that these
things-- at least on the
grid, the Markov chain case--
can get to their optimal--
the optimal value function
and the optimal policy.
So we'll finish
that up next time
and get into the more
interesting-- get rid
of these Markov chains to try
to get back to the real world.
Good.
OK, see you Tuesday.